last
year and a half
loving god as we gather here we're
incredibly mindful of all the events
of this last 18 months
and we remember with great fondness
friends
family colleagues
father as the gathered members here do
the
ongoing work and ministry in our
communities
help us to have a confidence in your
unchanging
nature your generous
love and the wisdom that you bestow
on each and every one of us as we seek
your direction
so lord i pray and give thanks
for councillor dre and his leadership
over this difficult season
we pray for the new chair and vice chair
who will be sworn in this day that you
would bestow upon them
all wisdom
so lord in all that is discussed this
evening
may we remember you those who we have
said goodbye to
that you might be honored and amnest and
our community is transformed
because of our ongoing work
amen
[Music]
thank you members
good evening everybody welcome to
rochefort district council's annual
council meeting
can i please take this opportunity of
welcoming all elected members to the
sorry all newly elected members to the
council at this first
formal rupture district council meeting
of this municipal year
namely councillor constable councillor
foster
councillor gadsden councillor jim
gooding councillor knight
councilman lorman councillor myers and
councillor lisa newport
i would also like to welcome all
re-elected members and all other members
council officers and members of the
public who are joining us
this evening at our very first physical
meeting in public
since 2020
but also i was also like to say farewell
to all those councillors who are no
longer serving as councillors following
this year's elections
namely councillor hookway councillor
hudson
councillor iodu council lucas gill
council belton and councillor burton and
thank them all for their service to the
council
and to the residents of rochester
district
finally thank you to the staff of swain
park school for assisting us
in holding this meeting which has been
presented which has presented challenges
for us with the need to comply with
covered
19 restrictions
members i shall now take agenda item one
this is to elect the chairman of the
council for the 2021 stroke
22 municipal year
members are there any
council button
thank you councilwood a second to please
councillor
thank you councillor other nominations
members
members we will now take a vote
if you could please raise your hands and
keep them raised while
officers count them for those members
who wish to
agree to nomination please raise your
hands please
so
so
so
thank you members please lower your
hands and eddie against please
thank you members any abstentions
thank you members that motion has been
carried there were 25
four four against and four abstentions
thank you so councillor julie gooding is
our chairman for the next
municipal year congratulations julie
so
so
hi mrs julie rosanna goodin have been
elected
to the office of chairman of the council
of the district of rockford
declare that i take the office upon
myself
and will truly faithfully fulfill
the duties of it according to the best
of my judgment
and ability i undertake to observe the
code of conduct
which is expected of members of rochford
district council
so
i would now like to present councillor
dre
past chairman's badge counselor
thank you madam chairman first of all my
alpha my congratulations to you on being
elected chairman
and i wish you an enjoyable year in
office
i would also like to thank carol weston
for her great support of
me as my vice chairman thank you carol
although there were no events for carol
to attend to my behalf she did a
wonderful job by assisting me at full
council via zoom
not an easy job i can assure you
i believe that he's left the premises
but i'd also like to thank my chaplain
reverend david oxtaby
for me being chairman has been a great
honor and privilege and i hope that i
have
during my term promoted rocha district
council throughout
essex and parts of greater london
members are aware that i was chairman
for two years due to the pandemic
my first year having been blighted by
the sudden sad death of my vice chairman
counselor terry cutmore i was pleased to
dedicate a memorial bench in terry's
memory
in the century gardens in raleigh
i'd had hoped to exceed 100 engagements
but due to the lockdown completed some
73 events
in approximately the first eight months
for me one of the highlights were those
engagements involving our young people
i was very impressed with their great
confidence and fabulous abilities
our future is in good hands
i'm delighted to have raised nearly 10
000 pounds in my first year
for my nominated charities despite
losing two fundraising events to the
lockdown
and my thanks go to all those who
supported me
especially councillor cheryl rowe for
her assistance
in helping to arrange these thank you
cheryl
i'd also like to thank councillor cheryl
rowe and council carol pavlin
for accompanying me on a number of
events as my reserve consorts
although a challenge i enjoyed cheering
for council meetings
and i hope that i was fair to all
councillors regardless of their
political colours
my intention was to facilitate honest
political debate
which i hope i managed i hope also
that i shall be the only chairman to
have chaired full council via zoo
not ideal but we managed to continue the
democratic process
my thanks go to all councillors and
officers of the council for the support
given to me
without which i would not have been able
to have done my job as chairman
i would like in particular to thank
lauren morris and
holy holly boyd who kept my diary call
him one of my drivers but especially
sonja worthington
and angela whose great support during my
turn particularly at fall council
was invaluable i'm also very grateful
for the tremendous support given by my
main driver tanya
who successfully guided us through many
engagements
lastly i could have not been chairman
without the unstinting support and
patience
of my wife evon who i hoped enjoyed my
time as chairman
as much as i did thank you
counselor
it gives me great pleasure in being able
to take this opportunity to say a few
words
about you when you succeeded councillor
david merrick
as chairman in may 2019
little did you know what would lie ahead
and that he would be you would be in
your post for
two years over those two years robin
supported by his wife evon has ably
carried out the ceremonial duties
of chairman meticulously and
conscientiously
and has been dedicated to the role
his first year was fairly standard in
carrying out the sewage duties and
attending events that mayor's
and chairman conventionally attend it
culminated in the
magnificent civic dinner at the launch
whilst we knew cobid was on the horizon
we had absolutely no idea of the scale
and devastation the pandemic would cause
we take this opportunity to pay tribute
to councillor terry cuphoff
who had been robbing vice chairman who
so sadly passed away
in april 2020 and who had loyally
supported him
without an immediate successor robin
kindly agreed
to carry on for a second term the past
year
speaks for itself where for much of the
time
we have all been confined to home and
working behind a computer screen
throughout his term of office robin's
calm
even-handed and classic style has
shone through and he has been an
absolute modern example of fairness
and everything we should expect in the
world of german
robin you have been truly exemplary
ambassador for rocha district council
for which we thank you
you mentioned but i just want to
conclude
my few words by saying one thing in
particular that you will be
remembered for that is
chairman you're on mute
thank you
thank you council orton
councillor mrs mason
thank you i'm not sure
the difficult and challenging past year
and recognise the service that council
robin drain has provided
history council i also noted council
darius comments
and i would like us to perhaps take a
minute to reflect on the dedicated
service
that councillors no longer with us for
you know various reasons have given to
this council
and i think why are we focusing on the
future today
which you also reflect on people that
have given us
this dedicated service and regardless of
the party
we should acknowledge that counsellors
give
service to the community and they give
service to the community
to the best of their ability whether we
agree or disagree
they are doing their best and i'd just
like to mention
the councils that we have no longer with
us because we've lost an
awful lot of experience in the last two
years councilman oaten
councillor john mason helsin nick cooper
councillor terrycat marcus who was a
one of the longest-serving counselors
councillor john griffin
sadly house of diane coyne and we will
certainly miss
the freshness that you brought to this
council
council daniel councillor
councilman hence
this isn't meant yeah this is
an acknowledgement of the service that
most people have given
and in recognition that all of us here
are going to give
certain stories thank you thank you
councillor mrs mason
we will now move on to agenda item
number three
to elect the vice chairman of the
council for
2021-2022
councillor mr wooten
thank you chairman i would like to
thank you
take a vote on this
those are in favor please raise your
hand
so
so
okay
thank you members you now may lower your
hands
can there is against please raise your
hands and keep them up while the
officers count them
thank you members finally do we have
any members wishing to abstain
so
that was 34
none against an eight abstained
thank you that motion is carried
please
so
there are 38 members
for your presents
sorry i couldn't hear you
correctly
[Music]
so
uh
thank you so just to clarify that is 26
for four against and four abstain
okay
hi michael johnstep having been elected
to the office of vice chairman of the
council
of the district of rockford the prayer
that i
that i take i declare that i take the
office upon myself
and we duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties
of it accordingly to the best of my
judgment ability
and undertake to observe the code of
conduct
which is expected of members of
rochester district council
councilor
madam chairman um it gives me
great pleasure to obviously congratulate
you uh being appointed
as our new chairman and of course
councillor steppo
being appointed as our new advisor so i
wish you every success in the
forthcoming year
and let us hope the forthcoming year is
a little
more normal for you both i'm sure it
will be
in past years but at this point
i would particularly like to and i do
support apologize you have
provided to the chairman
during the past year carol you have
been superb you were a
it was unfortunate the events that
occurred that
led you to be vice chair i'm sure you
would have knowledge
back that councilor western has
ably supported council robin grey
through the past year and we really
do appreciate that your experience
and my support has been much appreciated
thank you very much
it gave me the chance to support
councillor robin dre who stayed on their
chairman
during the last 12 months of the
dreadful kobe 19 pandemic
i think that with social distancing
measured relaxing in england
now is a good time for another member of
the council
to be given the opportunity to be chair
of the council
as i have back in agreed
this will free me up to concentrate on
issues of residence within my ward
and to also seek my growth of any local
issues
that may arise over the coming months
i will be able to contribute by
attending committee meetings
both as a member and in a visiting
capacity
in order to ensure my residents continue
to be represented by marriage
i would like to thank sonia burlington
angelo
and angela hutchings for their support
in me for the last year
and i'd also like to thank the outcome
chairman
councilman robin drake and i have
enjoyed the support over the past year
and congratulate the new chairman
mr wilkinson thank
thank you we will now move on to agenda
item five
and i would like to announce that nick
rowan has kindly agreed to serve as
chairman's chaplain for this municipal
year
agenda item number six apologies for
atkins
i have apologies for counsellor knight
are there any other apologies
no other apologies thank you
a gender item the minutes of the meeting
held on the 23rd
of february 2021
do members approve the minutes as a
correct record of the
meeting can i have a show of hands
please
that is agreed thank you members
agenda item eight announcements
from myself regarding the charity that i
have chosen
i have chosen a registered charity for
this year's
2021-22 it is a local charity
close to my heart and i have supported
them from the beginning
east essex hackspace is a hub which can
really benefit the local community
enhance emotional well-being through
socialisation and positive engagement
to date east essex hackspace
initiated a project of making thousands
of 3d
printed face shields for key workers
across the district
during the pandemic using their fully
equipped workshop facilities
to benefit our community they have also
reconditioned used laptops and ipads
donated by the public
for young people who were without
technology to access online learning
hackspace also work alongside another
charity called
remap remap is a charity which creates
bespoke items to help disabled people
live more independent lives
the space equipment will be made
available for remap
use these two charities working together
will continue to provide a needed
service for our local community
as well as the wider population thank
you
item number eight members district and
parish
council elections are these noted
members
thank you members agenda item 10
notice of group membership is this noted
members
agenda item 11 to appoint the executive
and committees 2021-22
i will ask miss lord to present
thank you chairman members the deputy
leader and associate
associated portfolio holders are as
advised by the leader and
for the council to note chairman a list
of portfolios has been circulated to the
members this evening labelled addendum
3.
chairman you are um you are to ask
whether members note the appointments
to the executive i set out in addendum 3
on page 11.13
i remember is able to note that please
thank you
thank you chairman secondly the
political composition of the council
should be reflected in the allocation of
seats on the council's committees
appendix 1 to the report set out at
pages
11.5 to 11.6
shows seat allocations based on the
current composition
in accordance with the pro writer rules
it also sets out the terms of reference
reference to all committees council is
asked to endorse appendix one chairman
will members endorse that please
thank you thank you members
thirdly chairman group leaders have been
invited to nominate to the council's
committees item 11
revised addendum 1 commencing on page
11.9
running to page 11.11
sets out the membership of committees as
they would be
taking on board the nominations that
have been received
can members please agree to endorse the
nomination set out in dunder 1 on pages
11.9
to 11.11 chairman
members do you end up saying thank you
chairman nominations have been received
from group leaders for
chairman and vice chairman of
commissions
these have been set out in addendum 2 at
page 11.12 and can be
endorsed subject to dealing with three
nominations that have been received for
the vice chairman of the development
committee
two nominations for the chairman of
licensing and appeals committee
two nominations for the vice chairman of
review committee
and two nominations for the chairman of
the statutory officer personnel
committee
chairman those nominations are
determined by voting with a show of
hands
so for the chairman of the chief officer
appointments committee can those members
wishing to vote for
councillor james newport please raise
their hands
thank you if you could lower your hands
members and can those members wishing to
vote for council wooden please raise
their hands
so
thank you remember that that is
councillor wilson
so for the vice chairman of development
committee can those members
we have 11 for council james newport and
27 for council of watson
thank you chairman so for the vice
chairman of development committee can
those members wishing to vote for
councillor eves
please raise their hands
thank you members
can those wishing to vote for councillor
smith please raise their hands
so
thank you members finally can those
members wishing to vote for council
wilson
please raise their hands
so
that is councillor smith thank you
members
members for the chairman of licensing
councillor eves nine councillor smith 27
council wilson ii
for the chairman of licensing and
appeals committee can those members
wishing to vote for council wilson oh
apologies council wilkinson please raise
their hands
and can those members wishing to vote
for councillor williams
please raise their hands
this
foreign
so
members that is council williams council
wilkinson has 11 votes
council williams has 26 votes there was
one no vote
so for the vice chairman of review
committee can those members wishing to
vote for councillor macpherson
please raise their hands
so
and can those members wishing to vote
for council wilkinson please raise their
hands
that is council mrs mcpherson with 27
votes
um councillor mr wilkinson received 11
votes
for the chairman of the statutory office
of personnel committee
and those wishing to vote for council
lawman please raise their hands
and can those members wishing to vote
for councillor lomney please raise their
hands
thank you that is councillor alumni uh
councillor newman 10 votes council
alumni 27 votes
chairman can members please now agree
the appointment of the chairman and vice
chairman of committees as set out on
page 11.12
of addendum 2 and subject to the
appointment appointment of council of
wooden
as chairman of the chief officer
appointments committee
councillor smith as vice chairman of
development committee
council williams as chairman of the
licensing and appeals committee
council mcpherson's vice chairman of
review committee and councillor
lomney as chairman of the statutory
officer personnel committee
thank you members we will now move on to
agenda item 12.
councilman this is
[Music]
there's 38 members present we've
clarified that
we have had an issue before when
officers have shall we say
not quite got the numbers right and then
we were
at the embarrassment of being told well
you have a
category of do not have to vote that was
then received and we now have
three categories which is logical
[Music]
to add up three categories of votes
and get them to agree to the number of
members present
thank you councilman i'd like that
chat thank you
we will now vote on the previous item
11.
members can i ask you to agree on 11.12
thank you on the attended two
agreed members thank you
we will now move on to agenda item 12.
members do you agree the scheme of
delegation has set out
in part three a and c of the
constitution
can those in favor please raise their
hands
and keep them up while the officers
count themselves
my apologies
the armed forces covenant champion
we have one two appointees
nominations have been received to
appoint an armed forces covenant
champion
for 2021 22.
these have been set up at addendum 4 on
page 11.14
for members wishing to vote for council
butcher please raise their hands
for those wishing to vote for councillor
wilson please raise their hands
that is councillor butcher
with 27 votes and council wilson with 11
votes
thank you chairman that concludes item
11 of business
members moving back on to agenda item
number 12.
do you agree the scheme of delegation
are set out in part three a and c of the
constitution
those in favor please raise their hands
and keep them up while the officers
count them
so
please lower your hands those against
members do we have any abstaining
do we have any members abstaining
thank you members that is 29 four
none against and nine absolutely
that motion is carried counselor
if some of our members could raise their
hands quite high i had to look around
just there
and it would be
thank you thank you for your help
agenda item 13
would members approve the scheduling of
council meetings on the 13th of july
19th of october 7th
of december or of 2021
the 15th of february and the 22nd
of february both of 2022
are these approved members
thank you agenda item 14
to appoint representatives of the
outside body
and other forums i will ask miss law to
present these items on 14.
thank you chairman council is required
to make the decision set out
on pages 14.3 and 14.4 of the report
the first recommendation is for the
appointment of officers and portfolio
holders to the outside bodies
for the 2021-22 municipal year
on the base is set out on page 14.6 of
appendix 1 to this report
and appointees are listed in the
addendum 1 on pages 14.9
and 14.10 this is to be agreed chairman
is that great members thank you
that then concludes the business for
these people
apologies members
secondly is the appointment of member
representatives including a number of
substitutes
for the 2021-22 municipal year
to the outside bodies set out on pages
14.7 and
14.8 of appendix 2 to the report
the names bodies and the nominations
received to them are set out in addendum
2
to the report on pages 14.11 and 14
to 14.12 that is to be a brew chairman
subject to dealing with the multiple
nominations
that have been received for some of the
outside bodies
to take these in turn
nominations have been received for
councillor sparing and council stanley
for the essex
flood partnership board can members
please raise their hands
if they want to vote for councillors
staring
can members please raise their hands if
they want to vote for councillor stanley
that is council sparing council sparing
27 council stanley 11.
nominations have been received for
councillor mike carter
councillor gadsden councillor knight for
two appointments to the hockley
community centre association
can members please raise their hands for
councillor mike carter
members can i uh please raise your hands
if you want to vote for council gadsden
members can you please raise your hand
if you want to vote for councillor
knight
um
members apologize should you make that
case three nominations for two
appointments
and that is counsellors carter and
councillor gadsden
council got carter received 27 votes
uh councillor gadsden received 27 votes
and councillor mrs knight on ms knight
to count
receive 10 votes moving on to the radio
grange community association governing
body
three nominations for two appointments
have been received from council lumley
council james newport council and
council sparing
can members please raise their hands if
they want to vote for councillor lovely
thank you members uh members please can
you raise your hand if you would like to
vote for councillor james newport
members can you please raise your hand
if you would like to vote for council
sparing
so
that is counsellors lonely and
councillor sparing council alumni 28
votes
council newport 11 votes and councils
sparing 27 votes
moving on to the really mount local
committee four nominations have been
received for one appointment
from councillors norman councillor meal
counselor james newport and councilman
mrs
newport can members please raise their
hands
if they want to vote for council of lawn
thank you members could you please raise
your hand if you would like to vote for
councillor milne
can members please raise their hand if
they wish to vote for councillor james
newport
can members please raise your hands if
you wish to vote for councillor
lisa newport
that's his counselor milne council
norman six votes councillor milne 27
votes
council james newport one vote
councillor
mrs newport for four votes
finally four nominations have been
received for one appointment to the
count
to the rocha100 association of local
councils for
councillor tony casa councillor fd
councillor stanley and council wilkinson
please raise your hands if you'd like to
vote for councillor tony carter
thank you members please raise your hand
if you wish to vote for councillor fd
and members can you please raise your
hands if you wish to vote for council
wilkinson
apologies
we will carry on with council wilkinson
i'll come back to councils then
apologies counselor stanley hey members
please raise your hands if you wish to
vote for councillor stanley
so
that is councillor fd councillor mrs
carter five votes councillor fd27 votes
council stanley three votes councillor
wilkinson two votes
chairman can the appointment set out
addendum 2 on pages 14.11 to 14.12
now be agreed subject to noting the
results of the votes that were just
taken
is that agreed members
thank you councillor mr mason
thank you
but when we're having three nominations
with two appointments some members are
voted twice
so what's the situation here because
some members get two votes and others
only get one
so if you just take great great
community centre
you have 28 votes 11 votes 27
that doesn't add up to 38.
therefore are you saying that we're
allowing people to vote twice
and therefore why can't other people
vote for us and say president i'm not
quite sure
i just want that clarified because it
doesn't seem democratic to me
german has expended three nominations
for two appointments
and um we can only appoint two
to um to those um positions
for example the radio grange so we need
to take each
each nomination and vote on them
so yes in in essence you would have to
you would be voting on each one of those
you have three votes well you need to
vote for two appointees
um from three numbers so you have three
nominations there's only two
appointments
so the the the the nominees the two
nominees with the most votes
at each vote will be appointed to the um
to the organization
thank you members
correctly so if we are voting for if
there are six nominations for three
places
we all have three votes that's how i
understand that ground no chairman you
would have to vote for each
nomination and the three with the
highest votes will
be appointed to that body
there are three appointees to a body we
can vote three
times for three individuals yes we can't
vote if there are six
nominations we can vote for three of
them if there's six nominations
you have to vote for each nomination
so we have six votes you have to vote
for each nomination
each nominee but we've been voting for
we haven't been
done
perfectly i thought it makes sense that
if we have three nominations we have
three votes
so
moving on
recommendation 3 relates to the
attendance by the leader of the council
and portfolio holders as the council's
representatives at the number of
external partnerships
as detailed in paragraph 3.4 of the
report
this is to be noted chairman
that noted members
wilkinson i really don't want to drag
this out and i'm sorry
when we come to iceland
because there are a number of names on
there
[Music]
there's seven appointees to the
partnership panel
um but there are eight nominees so you
will vote for the seven that you want to
sit
on the seven out the eight yes
i'm sorry you you can vote eight times
but you'll vote for the seven that you
want
apologies as i said before the nominees
with the highest number of votes
will be appointed to those organizations
yes so if so you vote eight times but
there's seven with the highest numbers
votes will get go through
every name that you put forward
and eight people nominated two those who
would only have seven votes
that's how it's worked in previous
capitals
recommendation three relates to the
attendance by the leader of the council
and portfolio holders as the council
director for sentences and a number of
external partnerships
as detailed in three of the report and
this is to be notified of the council
thanks channel is that noted members
cameron recommendation 4 relates to the
appointment of three seats on the
cemetery in watchful committee
for the 2021 municipal year we have
received six
nominations for three appointments for
councillors eaves councillors lumley
councillor meal council of jameson court
council lisa newport council laurie shaw
i set out in an addendum 3 on page
14.13 which will need to be determined
by voting chairman
can those members who wish to vote for
council eaves please raise their hands
can those members who wish to vote for
council lumley please raise their hands
so
hello members who wish to vote for
councilman milne please raise your hands
can those members wishing to vote for
councillor james newport
can those members wishing to vote for
council lisa newport please raise their
hands
thank you members and finally can those
members wishing to vote for councillor
uh laureen shaw please raise their hands
so
that is cancers lovely councillor meal
councillor
mrs shaw the votes are councillor eaves
11
council alumnus 27 councillor 27
councillor james newport 11 councillor
lisa newport 11
councillor mrs shaw 27
is that noted members
thank you
members recommendation 5 relates to the
appointment to the essex police fire and
crime panel
the nominations are set out in addendum
4 on page
14.14 to be agreed by the council
chairman
okay could you raise your hands
if you would like to vote for councillor
mrs butcher please
chairman this is a an appointment to the
essex police fire and crime panel
and i set out in um
addendum 4 on page 14
point 14.
the nominees are uh they've got held for
community and he's
and their substitute council ms butcher
recommendation six relates to the
appointment to the essex county-wide
traveler unit the nominations are in
addendum 5 page 14.15 to be agreed by
the council chairman
is that agreed members
recommendation seven relates to
nominations to four
seats on the local highways panel and
these are set out in addendum
six page fourteen point sixteen to be
to be agreed by council chairman we have
received
seven nominations for four appointments
for councillor eaves councillor christie
christie mason councillor mrs rowe
councillor phil shaw councillor stanley
council award and council mrs weston
which needs to be determined by voting
chairman
can members please raise their hands if
they wish to vote for accounts for
councillor eves
thank you members can you please raise
your hand if you wish to vote for
council mrs mason
thank you members please raise your
hands if you wish to vote for councillor
mrs roy
so
thank you members please raise your
hands if you wish to vote for council
phil sure
good thank you members
if you please raise your hand if you
wish to vote for councillor stanley
thank you members please raise your hand
if you wish to vote for council award
good
finally members please raise your hand
if you wish to vote for council western
so
so
chairman that is councillor mrs rowe
councillor phil shaw
councillor ward council mrs weston
councillor eaves 11 votes councillor mrs
mason
11 votes councillor mrs rowe 27 votes
councillor phil shaw 28 votes councillor
stanley
10 votes council's award 27 votes and
councillor mrs weston
29 votes
members is that agreed
thank you members
recommendation eight relates to the
appointment of two members and two
substitutes to the river crouch
coastal community team steering group
three nominations have been received for
two appointments
for the portfolio holder for environment
and place
council alumni and councillor stanley i
set out in addendum 7 on page
14.17 this will need to turn me in by
voting chairman
can members please raise their hand if
they want to vote for the portfolio
holder for environment and place
thank you members members please raise
their hands if they would like to vote
for council alumni
thank you members please raise your hand
if you wish to vote for councillor
stanley
we should be
votes again so whilst i understand
any votes that have taken place so far
cannot be re-run
i just would expect us to go back to
what was written in constitutional focus
um
sorry counselor now could you repeat
that paragraph for me please
there is no place in any of those
there were to be more than one vote and
then within seventeen point six
yes now there is there are
there were several nominations for um
olympus number seats and um the
it says here that the um
if there's no clear majority but we have
had votes and there has been clear
majorities in the votes
so for example uh in the
uh last vote we've just taken it's clear
that
the majority votes went to council road
council shaw
council ian ward and council weston the
other four
votes were knocked out that was uh seven
nominations for four appointments and we
have received
four four of the highest numbers the
four majority
the entire six paragraphs are written on
basis
this 17.6 as i understand was written
where there's one
seat we are talking about a numerous
number of seats
so if you have if you have seven
nominees there's seven votes one vote
for the nominee
it's each nominee counts as a separate
vote
so it's one vote per nominee council
canal
um
[Music]
council mr mason thank you
thank you
is
because logically
[Music]
and it's not what i would have expected
and i do hope that going forward this is
clarifying
and i had to say this employing
households
moving
i just wanted to check because it is a
little bit confusing
if we can vote
our monitoring officer has just
explained that we will have
uh the most amount of votes or each
person will get that position
that hasn't happened canceling this new
point
i would get the casting vote on that
situation
[Music]
each person would be voted upon and then
if there was an extra
vote for the eighth person as you've
illustrated
then i would get the casting vote
we need to move on with business now i'm
sorry i've taken the uh
your question on the back of that
because if we have
so many
that one person would be up for would be
up once you wouldn't be voting several
times for that person because the
nominee
you get it's one nomination
excuse me
where all of us voted for all the people
on the ballots are we saying that
the chairperson would then decide the
seven of those eights would go through
yeah kind of chairman a point of order
is intended to draw
a pursuit procedural issue to the
attention of you
as the chairman and ask rewarding we've
had a ruling
and i would suggest that this is taken
outside of the meeting we cannot go on
with this debate it is ridiculous too i
totally agree please can we move on it's
not fair
members recommendation nine relates to
the appointment of seven members
to the partnership panel on a pro rata
basis eight nominations have been
received for seven appointments are set
out in addendum eight
on page fourteen point eighteen
for those members who would like to vote
for councillor dre please raise their
hands
and chairman before we take a vote i was
hoping not to engage in this debate but
this is quite different from the
appointments for other outside bodies
whereas this is actually my uh pro
writer arrangement according to
uh parties so what i need to be clear on
is that there are five conservative
nominations on it there are five places
for conservatives and therefore what is
our position
and i would appreciate a ruling from the
monitoring officer so that we can be
clear on voting for the other
four nominations that we've put forward
so i would like clarification on that
thank you thank you for bringing that to
our attention
chairman um although um a decision was
made
by council back in september for this to
be
a pro-raster basis it is a matter for
this annual council to decide who sits
on
on that partnership panel this evening
if it ends up with um not under the
priority rules it wouldn't be illegal
because you are not
because it's not required to be on a
priority basis unlike your committees
councilor wilkinson thank you
in that case i checked and i wouldn't
withdraw council wilson
he was my nomination my group's
nomination um on the basis of what
uh the leader has said we're clearly
going to lose this one and i do not want
to
thank you council wilson
uh thank you council wilkinson um if you
have withdrawn the nomination for
council wilson then the
uh the appointees to the partnership
panel are councillors dre
councillors fd councillor
councilman lumley council sparring
councillor stanley and councillor
steptoe
german that concludes the item of
business
is that great members thank you
i declare the meeting
at 9 10. thank you members
uh